before the started we've got a lovely
gem lettuce salad at the Oscar luncheon
Thanks to be arrogant with your
champagne opening Cheers cheers to you
I'm glad we toasted because I heard that
you were the mischief maker no that's
what the : me well I was filling in
other people's seats so I really missed
up the seating arrangement I didn't it
didn't really obey that rule how many
rules do you really I bear the physical
rule of needing to continue breathing I
do that I'll stick with that one was
making all sorts of mess yeah yeah
that's right
charlisse is another one she's a red bag
no schools Joe's a seed but the Tuesday
straighter have a lot of the
rule-breaking who did you end up by in
the class photo by the way because I'd
love to see that I like that image of
everybody there knows next Katie guys
yes
and then bong joon-ho sip steps would
right from me ruin my phone that's what
he does he likes to eat he's he's
obsessed with sort of ruining my career
sabotaging my moments and as a nominee
you know he was I'm gonna be nominated
to you might just relax man I have to
know this next thing he gets nominated
as well just copying me do you do you
his Greta girl if she was in here and
she told me she's copying me as well
she's obsessed with me she's obsessed
he's just trying to get my back do
whatever I'm trying to do she's trying
to do it as well in fact most of those
people in their room if they trifle had
been honest
jealous next year she's gonna be funny
exactly
but um Greta she was telling me how two
years ago she actually made the
connection at the class photo with Meryl
Streep to do little women like Meryl
said I heard you do in Little Women I'd
like to do it at the class photo and
boom Meryl Streep's in the movie so do
you ever wear now I'm thinking about now
you've said it was too late for me
see when someone tell me that and about
the don't talk to these people be you
can have missed opportunity on cast
opportunity who ever wanted to talk to
in there nobody because I don't watch
other people's movies because I just
watched my own things hey ride dude
weather Sunday let's lazy Sundays I just
get my box set out of my films and just
in order just watch the more
back-to-back and then I put the
commentary on because I'm so interested
in what I could possibly say about my
films that's sort of me just like humbly
just watching my stuff as I wrap up in
my bed with myself and we do say that me
and myself yep but I thought the actor
part of me and the director part of me
had a really strong bond and we've been
working together for a while now
yeah well I just go say the engineer
there's something about me that I think
I want to continue working with this
guy's it was the talent they told me
that I've got a great eye for talent
sometimes that big search for talent
liji during into the mirror Archie yay
yep he's incredible we're obsessed with
him
where can we find him can I
in my pocket you feel like you know that
you do have this for maybe what's next
you know what I'm saying to kind of keep
people on their toes
[ __ ] do you know what he's doing
Thanks yeah but we found out he just
through the normal auditioning channels
but he had such an incredible presence
I've watched the little tape on the
casting website and stuff and he soon as
I saw him I saw his face I said okay if
you can act a lot he's in the movie and
just cast him right there just cuz it's
just this is something about you want to
keep watching him befallen love of them
listen what does approached even mean
I've seen Star Wars there's about a
thousand years ago
[Music]